what's going on guys this is Rob and if
you're enjoying the content here on my
channel then make sure you hit the like
button and make sure you hit subscribe
so you can decide what direction the
content on my channel goes in in the
foreseeable future
okay so we are picking up with Doomsday
Clock part two and really in order to
keep from like spoiling the events of
The Watchmen because I know that while
the story is like 50 years old or 40
years old or something crazy like that a
lot of people never read it I mean they
saw the movie but they never actually
read the comic so in order to keep from
spoiling the end of the comic we're not
gonna go too deep into what the
aftermath of the comic is or at least
what happens at the end of the comic
what we will say is that with regards to
where Doomsday Clock picked up it
basically picked up with the end of the
world the fact that everything had come
crumbling down and so really this deals
with like these these last vestiges
these last moments but for reasons that
were never really explained to us
Ozymandias had gone as far as to
basically recruit the characters of
marionette and mime I remember
marionette and mine were in a lot of
ways the not really Joker characters the
characters were kind of like comma just
two jokers now in truth the way there's
the way they're kind of being depicted
here it's almost like they're more of a
joker Harley Quinn relationship in the
sense that I would say Joker would be
more like a marionette and Harley Quinn
might be more like mine but we didn't
really know why awesome Andy has wanted
them so much we don't know why he
brought them in well what we end up
doing is get this kind of tape of course
Ozymandias basically gives them back the
things they normally neither their
outfits perfume for for marionette
different things like that but we end up
you know having this tape that's shown
to Rorschach and what this tape reveals
is that somewhere along the line over
the course of the careers of marionette
in Mon they had gone to rob a bank now
of course this bank robbery really kind
of played out the way we would expect it
to you in the sense that things went
nuts pretty fast but along the way there
basically greeted by the arrival of dr.
Manhattan now the crazy thing about this
is that dr. Manhattan would have just
incinerated them in their entirety and
that was the expectation you know from
like a bank manager from the bank
tellers the customers who were in there
they expected dr. Manhattan to just
obliterate marionette and mime in their
entirety the problem is that Manhattan
chose not to and the reason why was
because he basically realized that
marionette was pregnant now of course we
talked about this in the first video in
fact that's one of the biggest things is
hit on in the first video is that
marionette and mine had a child and they
wanted to know where it was I mean
there's a there's a point in the first
story where she's like where's my baby
yet so of course we know that you know
they they have a child together but it
is cool because one of the things it's
really kind of focused on when it comes
to Manhattan is this sort of lack of
concern about humanity this lack of
interest but one of the things that
really kind of also focuses on in the
a watchman is that if dr. Manhattan is
being human he's really being human in
name only in the sense that well this is
what humans would do so that's what I
will do like it's these little you know
these little tidbits of humanity that
are still somewhat part of his person
and kind of leaked out here and there so
to speak but the funny thing about this
is that Adrian Veidt didn't know that
Ozymandias did not know that marionette
was pregnant you know Ozymandias looks
as that and says well Manhattan chose
not to kill him because there's some
kind of connection they share something
along those lines it's desperation where
Ozymandias is the smartest man of the
world what he's doing is grasping at
straws the world is coming to an end and
we have to find dr. Manhattan in order
to save it he's the only one that can do
it and I'll believe anything I need to
believe in order to find him in times of
desperation people will believe whatever
they want to believe whatever will make
them more comfortable even if that
belief system defies all forms of logic
if it defies all forms of evidence they
will move those facts aside and they
will replace those facts with their own
opinions because it makes them feel
better about the reality of the
situation that's the nature of things
now the other thing about this is that
awesome Andy has also came to the
realization that dr. Manhattan glowing
blue is just a byproduct electrons
escaping his body but what it does is it
leaves a trail and so the argument of
Ozymandias is they can literally follow
it like breadcrumbs and they can find
out where it is that Manhattan went to
because with all the mande is's
explorations and his you know
investigations he's found nothing to
indicate that dr. Manhattan has moved to
some other place in the universe in the
mind of Ozymandias he's gone to a
different universe presumably the main
DC universe and so if the result is that
as these bombs begin crashing down
around everyone we ultimately end up
having the Watchmen Ozymandias and war
shack alongside mime and marionette
basically teleport to the DC Universe
and it's actually kind of cool because
what it does from here is it picks up
with Bruce Wayne now one thing I want
you guys to remember is that Doomsday
Clock is believed to basically take
place after everything that's going on
so far so Doomsday Clock takes place
after all the current stories that are
going on in DC rebirth right now after
the events of dark nights the metal all
is really kind of like after all that
stuff it takes place in the future how
far out we don't know we don't know if
like dark nights metal will end and then
immediately jumps into Doomsday Clock or
if there's a span of like a month or two
and then Doomsday Clock starts we just
know it takes place in the future and
the reason why we know that is because
for the most part the attitude of
society has
shifted where society you know
previously embraced superheroes society
has basically turned against superheroes
they turned against Batman they've
turned against Superman we don't want
you guys here now again we could really
attribute this to the aftermath of Dark
Knight's metal for example Barbados
leading all of his forces into the world
you know when attacking all the
superheroes all the citizens and
metropolis being converted in the
Domesday Gotham City has really kind of
come crashing down during the gotham
resistance tie-in for dark knights metal
all those things that are going on we
can really kind of presume that that's
when that takes place but that's all we
can do is make that presumption we don't
know with an absolute certainty that
that's the case the other half of this
is that Bruce Wayne has basically had to
undergo these sort of annual
psychological tests more or less to
satisfy the Board of Directors and the
reason for this is because of the fact
that the Board of Directors effectively
believes that Bruce Wayne is not capable
of leading his own company now the
reason why this matters is because Lex
Corp is currently in the process of
trying to buy Wayne Enterprises meaning
Lex Luthor would run everything Broin
Enterprises is in charge now
the immediate concern of Lucius Fox as
well as Bruce Wayne is if this happens
then basically the Batman project will
be exposed or it'll have to go
underground but we won't have the
resources we have now basically you'll
lose all your financial backing all your
gadgets all your little tricks all those
things those will all go out of the way
in truth it would actually see Batman
just kind of return to his to his golden
age form back in like the 1930s and 40s
when everything was pretty simple and
pretty basic I mean he still had things
like the batwing stuff like that but
what it basically means is that Batman
would no longer be the sort of fighting
force that he would be at the moment the
bat family would presumably go away
they're so Gotham would just kind of be
left to whatever criminals really just
kind of take it over and run it in its
entirety versus our only real concern
here is what we just need to worry about
Batman won't worry about that first
we'll try to figure out a way to keep
that to keep that solvent but as long as
I pass these psychological tests it
doesn't really matter picking back up
with the Ozymandias Rorschach mom and
marionette of course they crash land in
Gotham City and it's cool because as
they make their way into the city itself
they travel to the public library they
start to notice a lot of similarities as
well as a lot of differences now
remember from the world of the Watchmen
the way that story was written by Alan
Moore it was designed in a lot of ways
to be the real world The Watchmen was
designed to be like what would it be
like if heroes existed right now you
wouldn't have Superman flying around you
wouldn't have Green Lantern's you
wouldn't have Wonder Woman or anything
like that
the
extreme thing you would have would be a
guy like dr. Manhattan who gained his
powers from an intrinsic field in terms
of like superheroes per se you'd have
things like the Minutemen some group
that rose to prominence of 1939 you'd
have people who would just be running
around as vigilantes throwing on you
know makeshift masks and different
costumes and so on and just kind of
using whatever training or whatever
martial arts they've learned to try to
keep the streets safe and so when your
Ozymandias and you're looking around and
you start doing research on the city of
Gotham that you're in as well as the
world that you're in suddenly you start
learning about things like Superman you
start learning about things like Wonder
Woman you start learning about things
like Green Lantern you also begin to
notice these characters were fictional
in your universe and that's what
Ozymandias points out here in their
world Superman is a fictitious character
he's a comic book superhero Wonder Woman
is a comic book superhero Green Lantern
is a comic book superhero they've gone
from one universe where those characters
were pretend to stepping into a universe
where they're real it's very Grant
Morrison in terms of how it's done and
it's actually really really intriguing
but doing some more research and doing
some more poking around in the mind of
Adrian Veidt they can't just go to
anyone right they can't just go to
Wonder Woman or Superman or whoever what
they need are the smartest people and
that's for two different reasons the
first is because those smartest people
would be governed by logic and reason
the second is because of the fact that
those individuals will be able to help
them with whatever resources they need
you know using their intellect and so on
and so forth to help them achieve the
goal of tracking down and locating dr.
Manhattan and so the idea is to split up
Ozymandias himself will go after Lex
Luthor and Rorschach will go after
Batman so again it's cool because what
this does is it kind of bounces back and
forth between the two you basically end
up having war Shaq who shows up at Wayne
Manor manages to kind of break his way
in and then as he's going through
looking for clues and so on discovers
the clock that leads down into the
Batcave and Rorschach descends down into
the Batcave and triggers a trap set by
Bruce Wayne to alert anybody if anyone
enters the cave from there it switches
over to Ozymandias now this encounter
between Ozymandias and lex luthor is
amazing it is so cool and it's one of
the most interesting things out there
because remember with Lex Luthor he's
very arrogant in terms of how he
functions in who he is but remember
assuming this follows the events of Dark
Knight's Medal and everything that goes
on and assuming all things being equal
Lex Luthor's not a bad guy here Lex
Luthor is not a villain Lex Luthor is a
guy who's still a hero but he's still
Lex Luthor he still considers himself to
be the smartest man
in the world he's still very arrogant
he's still full of hubris he still
staunchly believes he's right in
everything he does but notice this and
this is kind of the cool thing the way
that Geoff Johns writes Lex Luthor and
the way that Lex Luthor interacts with
Ozymandias you never know he was a good
guy and the reason for that is because
you're not supposed to know if Lex
Luthor was written right in DC Comics
you wouldn't know that he was a good guy
until he put on a Superman uniform and
went to go save the day and that's why
it works you know to kind of sidetrack
for a second that's why you can shift
back and forth with Lex Luthor you can
have him be a villain when new 52 picks
up you can have them become a good guy
during the story of forever evil and
then you can have them you know stay a
good guy after forever evil and the
personality remains intact the arrogance
the hubris it all stays as a cohesive
part of what makes him who he is because
that's what people like that's what
people like about Lex Luthor they like
him being arrogant they like him being
like yeah I'm the smartest man in the
world like why wouldn't I be and it's
really kind of funny because him in
Ozymandias play off of each other
awesome and es is an initial answer to
the question from Lex Luthor you know
with regards to who are you is I'm a
smartest man on my world you're the
smartest man on yours and Lex Luthor is
like okay well then you're obviously a
bonehead and it's hilarious because what
is up happening is Ozymandias explains
everything that happens with regards to
the original Watchmen story and Lex
Luthor's responses and you really
thought humanity would stay together
like you thought that would be the thing
that would bring humanity together you
know you thought that you know having
some common force and the massive loss
of life would be the thing that would
unite humanity like if you're the
smartest person in the world I would
hate to meet the dumbest person in the
world now again this works beautifully
it worked so well because it's this
whole idea that Lex Luthor's just like I
mean that's not how I would have done it
and if it's not how I would have done it
then it was the wrong thing to do but
it's funny the way this exchange is done
because it's almost like Jeff Jones
basically saying Ozymandias is so far
out of his element Lex Luthor is so far
beyond Ozymandias in terms of who it is
that's smarter that it's almost comedic
speaking of comedic speaking of funny
while the two of them are basically
talking to each other of course you got
were shocked investigating the Batcave
while the two of they were talking to
one another a shot gets fired in the
office of Lex Luthor only for us to find
out that gunshot that bullet came from
the comedian how he's there I have no
idea I have no idea how the comedians
back I have no idea where he came from
no who
is and it's just like no way no way dude
I saw that and I was like Jeff jobs man
Jeff drives not only that you end up
having Rorschach in the Batcave and he's
met by Batman and Batman stay - you ate
my breakfast and Rorschach statement is
yes I did Batman and were Shaq meet each
other for the very first time with that
being said guys we're gonna bring this
video to an end if you are new here -
comments explain make sure you guys hit
the sub button to become part of the Rob
cork if you guys enjoy this video make
sure you drop a like and I will catch
you all later peace
[Music]